it's been a bumpy ride for US stocks in
recent months with markets hitting
historic lows blue chip companies and
market leaders like Facebook like Amazon
like Google all started a slump back in
October
investors were apparently reacting to
the ongoing trade war between America
and China and Christmas Eve saw another
plunge with US Democrats quick to blame
the president therefore today's events
have made one thing clear President
Trump is plunging the country into chaos
the stock market's down another 500
points
general mattis is stepping down Donald
Trump though sees the US central banking
system the Federal Reserve as the main
source of the problems in fact in a
tweet he even compared it to a powerful
golfer who can't putt some are blaming
the market instability on another source
computer technology they're going off on
another tangent around 85 percent of all
trade is controlled by programs designed
to buy and sell according to market data
now the algorithms work much faster than
humans and can check huge volumes of
numbers in seconds we heard from
economics professor Richard Werner about
this theory
he says central banks are behind the
instability I think mostly we're
witnessing the results of this policy of
central bank's massively expanding their
balance sheets creating a whole lot of
money and purchasing financial assets
and investors realizing that at some
stage you know this game can't go on in
the US the central bank has already over
the past year given clear signals that
they want to change things and they have
tightened and they have reduced their
credit creation their money creation and
also the signal that most people watch
interest rates which actually follow
growth they've they've been raising as a
result of strong economic growth in the
US I don't think that the trade war with
China or other you know interventions
that we've recently had are really the
key factor here
you